it's good to see you man
come on now you can do that right
look who said nicky but i was just
kidding carlos jesus somebody's uptight
oh listen this is where we're at hey
um the reason why we're here is is
obviously something very very important
right um i wanted to ask you when you
started hearing
the news about the numbers climbing and
climbing and the
and the um state of what india is going
through right now with kobe what was
your first reaction
well at first i was shocked that it this
is this is not to sound callous or
something
but i was shocked that it took this long
for it to get to that level
because you know the you know the
obviously the virus has been around for
over a year and i
just as well assumed it would have
happened to india sooner
and that's not based on anything but
sheer numbers there's so many people
there there
it's almost impossible to socially
distance over there
and i think it's uh it's one of those
things where
i think in a place like india a lot of
us feel like well
there's so many other things that can go
wrong to us over here we're not going to
worry about this one
and then i think they waited a little
too long
what is something that you want the
world to know
about what's happening in india right
now what do you think there's a message
you want to get across
think the message we want to get across
is that they're in a bad situation
and when we were in a bad situation even
though they're considered a
third world country they still helped us
they helped north america they helped
the rest of the world you look at the
medical staff in north america there's a
huge percentage of it that is south asia
um whether it be from india pakistan
bangladesh or sri lanka it's
from any one of those regions they've
given us a lot of doctors here
that have helped a lot of people on this
side of the world it's our it's our
duty to give back to them and help them
as much as we can
when you talk to people um about what's
happening over there
do you what are you what are you getting
from do you
see that people understand the gravity
of the situation
do you do you think people are focused
on it at all
over there yeah 100 um
but again when i speak to people back
there i have a friend a very close
friend of mine she lives in
in bombay and i asked her what's going
on she says it's terrible
but it's not so much in bombay it's
mostly in the north and in
in the other parts of india and uh she
said it's
it's affecting the more it's affecting
the poor neighborhoods
more because of the education and they
don't really
comprehend what's happening and oh you
know this is a
you know this is a thing where a lot of
people think they can pray away this
thing and i'm like it's not
that's not how this works it's nice to
have positive thoughts but it's also
nice to be realistic
they need help they need oxygen they
need anything we can send them they need
it
they need wood i mean they need
everything right now
so if people want to just they're seeing
this
they know it's happening and they want
to take action but they're not sure the
best
course right what do you suggest people
do
i really feel like you need to research
what it is who you're giving your money
to if you are going to donate that way
because let's let's also call it what it
is there's a lot of corrupt people in
this world
and indy is no exception to corruption
and
you know there's there's some real dirty
evil people out there that will use
these
tragic situations to try and as their
comeuppance you know like this
disgusting didn't even
do that to somebody um you know you can
see people are dying but you're just
going to try and make a buck out of it
that's not the way this should work
we've seen you um in india doing doing
your specials we've seen what they've
given
back to you what does india mean to you
what does it represent to you when you
think about it right now
you know although i've said this before
i was never born there and i've never
lived there i've always felt a certain
connection to it i mean yes it's the
home my parents is the home of my
grandparents
it's my entire lineage goes back there
i'm the first canadian born one
um in my entire family and um
so you know that india holds a very
strong place in my heart
and when i go there i feel at home so to
see something like this happen to a
place that you care about so much
it affects you a lot and you you try to
figure out ways in which you can help
but
again the this the information has been
so twisted over the past year and a half
you don't know what
which way to approach this still like
there's never been one definitive way
to approach what's happening with this
with this van with this virus
i mean look at canada itself look at
toronto i mean i was there in april
and that's when everything got locked
down again and i was like what the hell
how did how did canada go backwards
so if you look at it from that
perspective if canada can go backwards
it's quite easy for a place like india
to go backwards
among everything that happens around the
around this virus and pandemic where
there's misinformation
um many people not taking it seriously
people not knowing what to do right some
people just not just not understanding
what they can do
is there one thing that frustrates you
the most about the approach
that people are taking i think it's the
lack of uniform
in in the approach there's no there's no
one i like let's put it this way you
know you have a headache you
take a tylenol you know you you have a
sore throat you gargle with salt water
you know that these things will work for
certain things
but there's no one way of approaching
the pandemic there's no one way of
approaching coronavirus or covet or
whatever you want to call it
um everyone's like well no you should
wear a mask oh you shouldn't wear masks
you should wear two masks you should get
vaccinated and then wear them you
don't need a mask now you need a mask
it's the information is so
it's it's crashing into itself so often
that you don't know
which side to believe and then what
happens is it turns into
uh basically like religion as far as i'm
concerned you know you find which one
suits your narrative the best right
yeah you know when we're talking about
um
what's happening in india and wanting to
help and wanting to give back why do you
think it's important that we get the
message out to people
well look you look at how large the
south asian population is in canada
and what they've done in that country
and it's only right that we pay it
backwards to where we
where our roots are from that doesn't
mean we're uh
we're traders by any means it means that
we are
privileged enough to help so since we're
in that position i think
it's only right that we don't
you